a sus 61 años am ya salud jugadas e
historia esta economista que nació en
sanciveri que se desempeñaba como
vicepresidenta de tanzania se convirtió
este 19 de marzo en la primera jefa de
estado de su nación desde la residencia
presidencial ubicada en la capital
económica de este país africano llamó a
los ciudadanos a defender los valores
constitucionales
este es el momento de enterrar nuestras
diferencias como país y ser uno como
nación es hora de consolarnos mostrarnos
amor unidad mantener nuestra paz a
nuestra humanidad y patriotismo y los
valores de tanzania
la líder que cuenta con más de 20 años
de trayectoria política llegó a la
jefatura de estado tras la muerte del
mandatario john mago juli que se produjo
a causa de una afección cardíaca el 17
de marzo
las normas tan sanas estipulan que en
caso de que fallezca el presidente será
el siguiente en la línea de mando quien
asuma las funciones la nueva mandataria
figura como la segunda mujer en ocupar
una jefatura de estado en territorio
africano tras la etíope sale work zewde
se espera que el cuerpo del fallecido
mago fu lee quien negaba la existencia
del cobo y 19 se ha sepultado de este 25
de marzo en château su pueblo natal tras
el desarrollo de varios homenajes en su
memoria